[Music]
well what i want to talk about today is
how the earth is getting greener it's a
subject i've got interested in in the
last few weeks and months and some
really interesting new research on how
quite literally the planet is getting
greener as we speak um and there are
reasons why that uh why that's happening
and it's not in spite of
the technological
growth and economic development that
we're experiencing it's because of it
and that's what i think is so
interesting about it
about 20 years ago a man named charles
keeling who
discovered the increase in carbon
dioxide in in the atmosphere at least he
measured the increase in carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere for the first time he
noticed something about 20 years ago
which was that the amplitude of change
of the carbon dioxide graph was
increasing in other words in the
northern summer
the carbon dioxide level fell and when
the winter it went up again
and this change was growing so not only
was more carbon dioxide coming into the
atmosphere every winter moor was going
out of it every summer
and he was a bit puzzled by that you can
understand why moore's coming into the
atmosphere because of industry and so on
but why is more going out of it every
summer as well you know why is it going
up and down more and the answer he came
up with is there's probably more green
vegetation on the planet and everyone
said don't be ridiculous the earth's
being devastated by human activity so
there's less green vegetation well we
now have the data there's a satellite
which goes around the earth and it
measures the amount of greenery beneath
it as it does so and it comes up with
something called the normalized
difference vegetation index which is a
measure of how green
the land area of the planet is and it's
quite clear that for the last 30 years
it's been increasing
so
between 1982 and 2011 20 and a half
percent of the vegetated area of the
planet got greener and three percent got
browner so net there is an increase in
greenness uh all over the planet now to
start with people thought well that's
just farming you know we're where we're
farming we're using fertilizer and
irrigation so we're making things
greener but then they looked at it in
more detail and said well no it's not
just in the farmland areas it's also in
forests well maybe it's because northern
forests are getting greener because the
earth's getting a little bit warmer and
so
canada and siberia yeah sure the forests
are growing a little bit faster there
too
um
and then well maybe it's it's also
nitrogen fertilizer we're using more
fertilizer well that's as a bit of an
effect but it turns out that some of the
fastest greening is happening in places
like the amazon and the middle of africa
where there's very little nitrogen
fertilizer available and where it's not
because the climate's got warmer because
the climate has not changed much there
and
anyway quite warm enough it turns out
that there is actually a net greening
happening all over the world places like
the amazon rainforest
um uh and
so what uh people like rangamaini of um
boston university have done is they've
drilled down into the detail of the
actual pixels of the planet to try and
work out what's going on
and they find that they can explain
about half of it by increases in
rainfall because the world is a little
bit warmer we've got we've got more
evaporation from the ocean there's more
moisture in the air we get slightly
heavier rainfall so we tend to get a
little more greening so for example the
sahel region in northern africa um uh
between the sahara and um the equator
there it has got considerably greener
over the last 30 years in contrast by
the way to what was predicted when i was
younger which was that the sahel was
going to get drier and the sahara was
going to advance there's been a
considerable net greening of the sahel
but the other half of the greening
my nanny concludes and he hasn't
published this yet but he's talked about
it in talks the other half of that
greening comes from carbon dioxide
itself
in other words the fact that we're
putting more carbon dioxide into the air
means there's more fuel to grow plants
and when a plant has more carbon dioxide
in the it doesn't have to open its pores
so much so it doesn't lose so much water
in absorbing the carbon dioxide that it
needs to grow and so there's tons of
experiments now showing that plants grow
faster if there's more carbon dioxide in
the air roughly speaking on average um
for a 200 parts per million increase in
carbon dioxide in the air you get a 30
improvement in plant growth
that's experiments both in the field and
in the laboratory so it's really quite a
remarkable
phenomenon here because of the burning
of fossil fuels
we're making the planet greener
it's an astonishing discovery i think
i think it's rather amazing and of
course it's an incredibly unwelcome
discovery for the environmental movement
they don't want to hear this at all and
how is it possible i mean after all
weren't we supposed to be devastating
the planet the population has doubled in
my lifetime the population of the world
has doubled we've got we're about seven
billion people we're about three and a
half billion when i was born it's not
all my fault but it has
increased
and
and
of course we've and during that time
instead of getting poor and miserable
and hungry like we were told actually
we're getting considerably better fed
and healthier we're living 30 longer on
average than when i was born
um and we've got 25
per more food per head
than when i was born so in other words
despite doubling the population we got
more food to go around than we had when
i was young
and yet the earth is getting greener
this hasn't come at the expense of of
the ecosystem so there's something wrong
with the model that says that economic
growth comes at the expense of resources
at the expense of the environment it's
certainly possible at least until this
point to have an improving environment
and an improving living standards and an
increase in numbers of people
and when you think about it it's pretty
obvious what's going on to some degree
if you take for example food
we
use 65 percent less land to produce the
same amount of food as we did in 1950.
sorry 1960 50 years ago
um that's a a an accurate measure that's
been done by jesse orzabel and paul
wagoner and colleagues at rockefeller
university they've taken all the
different crops in the world and they've
measured the changes in yield in
different parts of the world and they've
summed it all up and the crop production
index shows that that you need about a
third as much land to produce the same
amount of food as you would have done 50
years ago and that means of course that
you don't need so much land so you can
spare a lot of the land
they actually calculate that we've now
passed peak farmland
in other words we're not going to need
as much farmland from now on to feed a
growing population of the world we're
actually going to
cut the amount of farmland we had or
rather we would be able to cut that
number
if it wasn't for the biofuels program
i'll come back to that in a minute but
that's
that's the that's the spanner in the
works
and they they reach that conclusion
despite making very conservative
assumptions about the rate of population
growth about the rate at which people
will take up meat eating in poor
countries as they get rich etc they make
all these assumptions and they say that
even if you assume some pretty high
rates of increased consumption and
increased numbers we're still going to
need less and less farmland as we go
into the future
as indigony has calculated we
farm about 38 of the land surface area
of the planet at the moment
if we were using the yields of 1960 we'd
need to farm 82 percent of the planet
area bangor the rainforest bangor the
swamps bangor the deserts you know there
would be nothing left for nature if we
were doing that so thank goodness for
nitrogen fertilizer which is what has
made this possible
but of course where does nitrogen
fertilizer come from comes from the air
but we make it with methane we use
fossil fuels to make it so if it wasn't
for fossil fuels we'd be in a lot more
trouble naturally
so what's going on is land sparing by
improving productivity
of agriculture and other industries
and of course it's the same not just for
growing fuel but not growing for food
but for growing fiber and other things
too
land gets spared we reduce the amount of
land that we need to feed people
and the consequence of that is we can
release land back to nature
and as a consequence there is net
reforestation going on in about half the
world at the moment
uh
basically the forest transition the
point at which a country starts stops
losing forests and starts gaining forest
comes at about four thousand dollars per
capita gdp at about that rate the forest
loss tends to stop and tends and forest
tends to get replanted nobody quite
knows exactly how this happens it's
partly political pressure when people
get rich enough they start minding about
things like this and they start
demanding that forests be replanted but
it's also just because the the
productivity of the of the uh
economy is such that you don't need to
to put such demands on forest so for
example countries like bangladesh
have increasing forest cover at the
moment and vietnam and the dominican
republic countries like this are
increasing forestry over my own country
the uk has trebled its forest cover
since 1900 it's heading back towards the
levels at last had at the time of the
doomsday book in in 1086
and of course since in
america it's very obvious that this is
happening particularly on the east coast
new england used to be 70 farmland it's
now 70 woodland
what about
uh biodiversity and species i mean we're
said to be in the middle of a great
sixth extinction the great extinction
crisis
um but actually when you look at the
numbers
the rate of extinction of the animals we
know about and can measure is actually
quite low at the moment it has been very
high as a result of mankind's activities
particularly in the late 19th and early
20th century we caused a massive wave of
extinction of of animal and of mammals
and birds in particular um but nearly
all on islands
all the extinction problems basically
were all about killing off uh endemic
species on on islands like hawaii and so
on by the releasing of rats and other
predators and pests that decimated them
if you leave out islands
and if you count australia as an island
which it is in
ecological terms
then the total number of bird and mammal
species
that have been driven extinct
by human beings since 1500
is 9.
it's quite a striking number that
hundreds more on islands but
as long as you don't have subspecies
your own cat species
so the passenger pigeon and the carolina
parakeet are two of those nine for
example um but the heathen is not
because it's a subspecies cetera so
it it's a in other words
and and people say well you you know
stop trying to make out that there's not
a problem here there is a problem you
know humans are uh destroying habitats
and and actually i think that
conservationists should be crying these
numbers from the rooftop saying look
what a good job we're doing because an
awful lot of these species are not
there's an awful lot of species that
would have gone extinctive
conservationists hadn't helped them
hadn't
gone out and done something about it
gorillas were down to 200 mountain
gorillas about uh 15 20 years ago
there's now about 800 so you know that's
a great success story there's so many
success stories out there that are made
possible by the fact that there's
economic growth so people don't need to
destroy forests they can have jobs in
cities instead and things like that
i want to end with a couple of anecdotes
one is about um the island of
spitsbergen right near the north pole
where i spent a summer 30 years ago
with some friends in tents and uh we
were camped next to a little hut called
pluto hut in the valley of rheindel and
on spitzberg in a beautiful area
and um
we slept every night in our tents we had
we put no guards out or anything we
didn't need to worry about polar bears
there were no polar bears on the west
coast of spitsbergen it was a ridiculous
idea that one would even dream of
worrying about it then
last summer i inquired about renting
that hut i don't like sleeping in tents
anymore but i thought the hut might be
all right um
for a week with some friends says let's
go back there
and i was told no you can't use that hut
anymore it's been destroyed by the bears
polar bears are
extremely common on the west coast of
spitzeburg and now which they weren't
when i was young it's nothing to do with
the fact that the ice has gone because
the ice with the west coast of
spitsbergen is never had ice in the
summer anyway it hasn't for 500 years so
it's just an increase in numbers the
goose colonies on the offshore islands
are now
failed to produce a single gosling for
the last five or six years now because
polar bears eat all the chicks etc so
the polar bear numbers are right up so
the ringed seal numbers in the in the
fjords so the walrus numbers the the
fjord we were camped next to didn't have
horuses when i was there now there are
lots of walruses in that in that fjord
the white whale numbers have trebled in
that area um there's been a massive
improvement in arctic wildlife is my
point
it's not greener because most of these
things are brown or whatever but still
the the point is that the the wildlife
is thriving in the arctic
it's the same in the antarctic when you
think about it fur seals king penguins
around antarctica their numbers have
shot up
why it's very simple we've stopped
killing them all these creatures used to
be hunted
for their fur or for their blubber or
something like that so there was you
know there was a massive industry
exploiting these creatures which has
petered out and it's petered out partly
because of pressure from
conservationists but partly also
because the products it produces are no
longer needed because we get them from
fossil fuels instead we don't need whale
blubber or walrus blubber um
it was the discovery of petroleum that
meant that we didn't have to continue
hunting whales for whale oil to the same
extent
and likewise we've all got central
heating because of
fossil fuels and so we don't need
polar bear furs in our in our houses
so my point is simply that
you know when you think about the
recovery of wildlife in areas where it's
doing well
an awful lot of the credit goes to
technology and growth and economic
development
rather some of the credit goes to
conservationists i'm not saying that
they're not important but i am saying
that one uh the things that get blamed
the economic development is actually
part of the solution not part of the
problem
the other story i want to mention is the
island of hispaniola which is divided
between two countries haiti and the
dominican republic on this map haiti is
green and the dominican republic is
yellow that's the wrong way round
actually because if you were to look at
a satellite photograph of those two
countries haiti is brown the dominican
republic is green the border stands out
like a sore thumb on satellite
photographs
why is that
it's because haiti relies on renewable
energy
haiti fuels not just its domestic
economy but its industrial economy using
charcoal basically it's 98 deforested
because everybody's using wood for every
day for the main fuel for the entire
country the dominican republic imports
fossil fuels
and it subsidizes propane as a cooking
fuel so that people won't go out into
the forest and cut down trees
uh to cook over
so in other words it's the it's the
fossil fuels that are sparing
um uh the forest in the dominican river
the dominican republic forest is
increasing the remarkable thing about
fossil fuels when you think about it
is that when we use them
no other animal is deprived of its
livelihood
in other words we're not pinching them
no other animal wants to eat coal or oil
or gas
when but they there you know if you cut
down a tree to burn it you're depriving
a woodpecker of its life or if you kill
a whale you're depriving a killer whale
of its livelihood um
a lot of these renewable energy sources
are actually we're competing with
wildlife for it the great thing about
fossil fuels is you're not competing
with wildlife
which brings me to bio energy
at the moment we're spent we're
diverting about five percent of the
world's grain crop
into motor fuel to run cars instead of
to feed people
that's saving about point six percent of
the world's oil use it's it's cutting
our oil use by about point six percent
which is trivial it's having very little
impact on our use of oil but it's having
an enormous impact on the price of food
as we know fruit prices have doubled in
the last couple of years that's almost
entirely because of this diversion of 40
of america's maize crop for example into
biofuel
and that is driving up hunger and it's
causing starvation there's no question
about it people are being tipped into
malnutrition and even death by this by
this policy
and it's encouraging the destruction of
rainforest because by putting out the
price of food it encourages people to
cut down rainforest and plant
food instead it's happening in and
either to plant fuel like
bio
palm oil in southeast asia or to plant
food instead
so this policy and britain by the way is
is pursuing a policy of of uh trying to
encourage the burning of wood
to produce electricity we're setting up
wood fired power stations all over the
country and at the rate we're going
within five years we will have enough
wood burning capacity that is roughly
five times the total
product the total amount of wood we can
produce in the country so we'll be
importing eighty percent of it quite a
lot some of it's coming from california
already there's wood products being
shipped from california to northern
england to be burned for green energy
a it produces more carbon dioxide than
coal
particularly if you ship it halfway
across the world b it's being pinched
from woodpeckers in california i i
simply don't understand how people think
that this is is good for the planet
so
my argument is simply that the planet
surprisingly is getting greener at the
moment
it's getting greener because of carbon
dioxide because of climate change
because of
the fact that we're needing less land to
produce our food
and that greening
is actually good news and it's not
happening
in spite of what we do in terms of
economic development it's happening
because of economic development thank
you
[Applause]
you